cooking with lynch's tick tocks are
certified busting this self-proclaimed
regular mom with killer cooking skills
is changing the cooking game from new
spins on classic recipes to trying out
the latest trends taking over tik tock
her videos will make you hungry for more
that's busting blessing but what sets
linja apart isn't only her scrumptious
recipes it's her quick and creative
editing style she's made all her own
garlic
it's no wonder her videos have garnered
her two streamy award nominations in
cooking and editing
oh and not to mention her over 7 million
followers and over 115 million likes
amazing
lynn
aka
ninja
welcome
i'm so excited to be here i am so
excited that you are here how do you
feel about building an empire ninja
i'm
so surprised but so happy to make people
so happy and your son helps you right he
helps edit your videos yeah my son's the
genius behind cooking with linda he does
the editing the script writing oh is it
so fun to collaborate with your fans oh
it is
it has been remarkable working with my
son tim we've become so close
and
it's been the loveliest thing
i love hearing that
now how did you get the name linda
well my
when the boys were little they loved the
mutant um mutant ninja turtles yup and
so my eldest daughter combined my name
lynn
with ninja and came up with ninja so
they were my four
little ninja turtles and now all my fans
i call them my ninja turtles
that's very sweet
all right well uh linda
i would like for you to teach me and us
if you will what are we making today
okay so here we have some
butter and sugar that have been creamed
got it and then you add
the vanilla okay
and does this cookie have a name linda
it's called the walnut crescent cookie
and then the almonds walnut crescent
cookies
and then the flour got it
and then mix it okay
uh-huh well this is very satisfying yeah
it'll just come
it'll become a dough pretty quickly okay
mine is years away from becoming a dough
linda like
i i might be mixing till tomorrow
however
we have the magic of the proper dough
right here right so you take the dough
and you put it in the refrigerator for a
few hours okay and that's important too
yes don't skip that step because the
sugar and the
and the butter kind of meld together
like coagulate the
coagulate yes then you take
a uh
like about a tablespoon tablespoon of
the dough okay
then
kind of roll it
into a little tube
okay put it on your oh cookie sheet
and form it into a crescent and then you
and then what do we do we just
take a little powdered sugar and just
kind of roll it sprinkle sprinkle every
cookie with it okay
i did go all out i'm all happy
i got a real heavy hand in the kitchen
fine the more the merrier okay good
thank you and then you bake at
3 25 for about 12 to 14 minutes and then
the end result is
they come out looking like this
and
when they come out of the oven do they
come out like this or do they come out
like that do you have to add any little
snow you have to add a little snow i
just want to keep doing this now okay
because it's fun
okay so then you take your cookies out
and then you make them snow okay i love
this and where did you learn this recipe
well this was um my mother's walnut
crescent recipe from my childhood really
and when i make these cookies
um it makes me feel like i'm with my mom
again
i thought that i loved you and your
son's stories but i love how you're
connecting your mom into it too and
keeping a whole family circle going well
may we all transfer the beautiful heart
and soul of these cookies and your
family and go to the
drewberrymotion.com for the full recipe
thank you very much thank you so much
thank you so much
[Music]
you